[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour débuter ce mois de mars pour un
tour d'horizon de l'actualité de la
semaine dans le département
tout de suite les titres de ce vendredi
1er mars journée mondiale de la
protection civile ce 1er mars et d se
courir forme et nous ferons le point sur
leur action avec valérie sow toujours
vice-président de la protection civile
des yvelines et comment se forme et
justement pour intervenir lors des
festivals et événements publics comment
prodiguer des soins allant de la simple
bobologie aux gestes vitaux
zoom sur leur formation à poissy salon
de l'agriculture campagne de françois
asselineau ou encore expositions comme
chaque vendredi
coup d'oeil sur l'actualité de la
semaine chaque 1er mars
on célèbre la journée mondiale de la
protection civile identifiables grâce à
leur uniforme et véhicule bleu et orange
la protection civile apporte assistance
aux populations face aux catastrophes
naturelles et celles dues à l'homme
nous avons suivi de leur formation à
poissy pour intégrer leur structure
regardez et des se courir fort mais
c'est la mission de la protection civile
qui est l'intermédiaire avant l'arrivée
des secours
douze personnes sont en formation à
poissy pour intégrer la protection
civile
c'est une formation qui se déroule sur
35 heures avec tous les jours des thèmes
différents qui sont abordés avec
des parties théoriques des parties
techniques où on manipule les différents
les différents matériels et une partie
avec des cas concret qui sont évaluées
pour valider ou non la formation au bout
de la semaine au mazel un projet de
reconversion professionnelle pour
devenir infirmière donc c'était une des
choses qui m'a qui m'a motivé c'est de
mettre un premier pied dans le domaine
non pas médical mais de la sécurité du
soutien à la population
ce retraité sapeurs pompiers des
yvelines pendant 40 ans et formateur
pour la protection civile
il souhaite continuer à transmettre ses
connaissances acquises au service de la
population
ces gens quand le psc1 deviennent
équipier secouriste de façon pouvoir
assurer après des déposes hausse à la
portée sociale
ça veut dire que la formation qu'est la
halle et certificatif c'est à dire que
c'est pas une obligation que tout le
monde sur les reçus à la fin de la
semaine
contrairement aux pc voilà nous là ces
formations ni creuser pour tout le monde
va c'est vraiment des gens qui sont en
équipe qui vont travailler avec du
matériel avec un véhicule
donc il faut les former donc faut une
validation durant cette formation d'un
coût de 300 euros ils doivent apprendre
pendant une semaine tous les gestes de
secours à appliquer en toutes
circonstances une importance qui pousse
certains à intégrer la protection civile
mais par son mmo familial qui le fait
que j'ai dû faire un massage cardiaque
et j'étais pas vraiment formés donc je
me suis dit il faut que nous forme pour
le faire si jamais ça un événement reçu
rien cinquante personnes sont
actuellement au sein de la protection
civile des yvelines un nombre de
bénévoles qui pourrait augmenter à
poissy les douze personnes en formation
ont leurs résultats aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui journée mondiale de la
protection civile et nous accueillons un
plateau valérie so joe vice-président de
la protection civile des yvelines en
charge des formations pour jour bonjour
une des missions de la protection civile
et de formés au secourisme temps ces
bénévoles que les particuliers ou les
entreprises
on a vu justement dans le reportage ces
douze personnes en formation pendant une
semaine pour intégrer la protection
civile
alors ils ont réussi alors nous avons
neuf réussites sur 12 en sachant que ce
sont sur douze personnes dix personnes
qui étaient déjà au sein de nos équipes
titulaires de là
as prévention civiques de niveau 1 donc
tous publics qu'ils ont participé en
tant que stagiaire à des postes de
secours et qu'ils ont souhaité évoluer
pour avoir en effet la qualification de
manier vrai avec du matériel et de
vraiment est intégré en tant qu'équipier
au sein des équipes de secours alors
dans cette formation une partie
théorique et une partie pratique
concrètement qu'avez-vous fait avec eux
pendant une semaine
en fait cette formation leur permet de
découvrir tout ce qui va être les
manipulations de matériel et des
techniques qu'on va avoir à faire en
poste de secours ou en manifestation
particulière par exemple si on leur
apprend le massage cardiaque on va leur
expliquer comment détecte un massage
cardiaque
pourquoi il peut y avoir un massage
cardiaque quels sont les signes d'un
massage cardiaque
donc ça va être de la théorie est en
fait la pratique ça va être les maîtres
face à un mannequin leur apprendre comme
on fait le massage cardiaque
le bouche à bouche l'insertion de
l'oxygène puisqu'ils ont du matériel et
la mise en place précoce du
défibrillateur automatique alors
justement si des personnes nous
regardent aimeraient bien s'inscrire
comme bénévole quels conseils leur
donnez-vous alors de venir nous voir sur
les postes de secours c'est le soit
comme ça elles verront directement nos
interventions
sinon elle peut nous laisser un message
sur notre adresse mail un contact arbas
protection s'ils sont dix huit points
org qui permet en fait d'avoir un
contact directement avec avec notre
secrétaire général et le président est
d'ailleurs ce soir à 20h30
nous avons une réunion de gens bénévoles
intéressés sur le site de poissy donc
notre un autre salle de formation
alors je le rappelle vous êtes la
vice-présidente de la protection des
yvelines pourquoi avoir choisi
personnellement et d'intégrer la
protection civile
alors en fait moi celui secouriste
depuis 1991
parce que j'ai eu
des manifestations je faisais partie
d'associations j'ai rencontré la
protection civile où j'ai vu leur
intérêt la porte qui le donnait à la
population et puis bah voilà ça m'a
intéressé j'ai commencé bas par le bas
de l'échelle entre guillemets et puis
j'ai passé les examens au fur et à
mesure pour arriver à être et formateurs
et donc secouriste
au sein de la protection civile active
un autre public connaît aussi très bien
la protection civile ce sont les sans
abri à leur intention vous assurez des
maraudes régulières et ce quelles que
soient les conditions climatiques
réconfort délivrance de kits d'hygiène
ou prise en charge d'urgence font partie
de vos missions que constatez-vous sur
le terrain alors nous nous sommes donc
en contact et pardon dans ces cas là
avec le 115 puisque c'est eux qui nous
déclenché pour nous dire voilà à tel
endroit à telle adresse un sdf donc deux
possibilités soit cette personne ne
souhaite pas du tout intégré le système
du 115 parce qu'il sait qu'il ya pas de
place ou qu'ils préfèrent adore
malheureusement c'est un constat de plus
en plus régulier donc à ce moment là
nous allons délivrer bains où des soupes
chaudes de la nourriture couvertures ou
autres et pour l'été bat des bouteilles
d'eau tout simplement ou des kits en
effet d'hygiène ensuite s'ils le
souhaitent et si on peut on essaie de
lui trouver une place dans les sites
d'hébergement
aujourd'hui rencontres une par contre de
plus en plus de jeunes et qui sont un
petit peu en dehors de la société qui
ont du mal à justement à se réinsérer
dans cette société triple action donc
secourisme formation et aide sociale car
hormis la maîtrise du feu vous possédez
des compétences identiques à celles des
pompiers qu'elle est l'intervention qui
vous a le plus marqué la pire les
attentats du 13 novembre
tout simplement le bataclan on va
refermer cette page tragique
vous êtes donc une cinquantaine de
bénévoles dans les yvelines
dernière question comment ça se passait
ce qu'il y à des astreintes
alors nous avons au sein du conseil d
administration des personnes qui sont
donc actives qui sont
on est trois ou quatre en fait à das
train alors au téléphone donc sommes
peuvent physiquement sur un lieu et dès
qu'il ya une catastrophe qu'elles soient
naturelles ou chimique ou technologiques
ou autre la préfecture contacter la
personne d'astreinte et à partir de là
nous déclenchons nos secouristes via un
système de sms par notre logiciel
informatique et à ce moment là les gens
ne nous répondent s'ils sont disponibles
ou pas et puis on met en place le départ
des véhicules pour partir sur
intervention
merci enfin des risques dieu je le
rappelle vous êtes la vice-présidente de
la protection civile des yvelines en
charge des formations
merci d'avoir été notre invité en cette
journée de la protection mondiale en bas
de l'écran s'affiche le site de la
protection civile des yvelines
juste en bas merci merci à vous tout de
suite on passe au reste de l'actualité
de la semaine
[Musique]
à paris le salon international de la
grille de l'agriculture se termine ce
dimanche pour la seconde année les
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine participent ensemble au
salon
le but promouvoir sur un stand commun
leur territoire de nombreux producteurs
et blénod a été présent je suis parti à
leur rencontre au salon de l'agriculture
2010 9 dégustation de produits du
terroir français
découvertes gustatives visite
incontournable des animaux et petit
bisou pour certains je compte devenir
agriculteur dans quelques mois
et ça me semblait intéressant une c'est
une opportunité pour moi de venir de
voir un peu autre chose
et parmi tous les stands du salon
bientôt du vin 100% yvelinois en 2017 la
winery parisienne a planté ses premiers
pieds de vigne à d'avron elle veut
réinventer la filière viticole en
ile-de-france privé pour nous était de
reproduire des vins dans la plus grande
d'anciennes plus grandes régions
viticoles de france les villes de france
pour produire des grands vins dans la
région dans la plaine de la paix
la première cuvée est annoncée pour 2020
côté assiette la ferme d alu et propose
des légumes anciens et nouveaux
sur les étalages topinambours radis noir
ou rutabaga j'ai une cinquantaine
d'hectares
fruits et légumes que je revends sur les
marchés en ile de france car autres aux
choux de bruxelles rouge novembre
vraiment des légumes qui sortent de
l'ordinaire
le département des yvelines est le
deuxième territoire agricole d'île de
france
il participe au salon pour la deuxième
fois avec les hauts-de-seine et ils sont
complémentaires parce que l'agriculture
c'est une production et une consommation
et si les yvelines sont un département
producteur ce que les hauts-de-seine ne
sont pas les hauts-de-seine comme les
yvelines d'ailleurs sont des
départements consommateurs et en
particulier consommateurs dans nos
cantines scolaires de nos collèges les
yvelines favorisent les produits locaux
et intègre les produits issus de
l'agriculture biologique au concours
général agricole
y a eu la médaille d'argent sur un
yaourt à l'abricot destinés à la
restauration collective pour les enfants
des écoles du département audio
bio on va envoyer les 30 à 40 kg par
mois qui sont dédiés aux
quand une hôpitaux le territoire des
yvelines est composé de 90 mille
hectares d'espacés agricoles
avec près de 1000 exploitations
l'agriculture c'est un marqueur fort des
yvelines aider à l'installation et au
renouvellement des générations
il faut installer des jeunes
agriculteurs des jeunes agricultrices et
donc on y travaille en les aidant
financièrement on les aide aussi à se
transformer au niveau écologique
énergétique
alexandra dublanche également adjointe
au maire de sartrouville n'est pas la
seule à vouloir mettre en avant les
agricultrices dans les stands du salon
clémentine errigo miss france agricole
élu le 15 décembre est présente c'est
plus les vieux barbu au fin fond de la
montagne qu'il ya vraiment un nouveau
souffle dans le monde agricole avec la
jeunesse et les femmes dans
l'agriculture
concilier développement urbain et
développement économique agricole un
enjeu que les visiteurs ont apprécié sa
mort
en son nom
on fait voir beaucoup des choses qui à
paris justement il n'y a pas de saint
canut et à chaque fois j'ai eu
l'occasion d'accompagner mon petit fils
j'avais pas mal de nouveautés
c'était du côté bio et goûter les
produits éventuellement vous pouvez
encore faire un tour le salon de
l'agriculture se termine ce dimanche 3
mars
candidat à la dernière présidentielle
françois acelino sera aussi tête de
liste de son parti l'union populaire
républicaine aux élections européennes
de mai prochain
en attendant l'ouverture de la campagne
officielle il réalise actuellement un
tour de france loin des médias nationaux
qu'ils accusent d'ailleurs de ne pas lui
donner assez la parole il faisait escale
mardi soir à rambouillet pour défendre
l'idée du fch exit alors que l'accord
définitif pour entériner le break beats
peine à arriver c'est bien l'idée du
fric site que françois asselineau
souhaitant poser lors de la campagne des
prochaines européennes sortir de
l'europe de l'euro et de l'otan une idée
qu'il défend depuis maintenant 12 ans sa
formation lui père à d'ailleurs été
lancée au lendemain de la création du
marché commun par le traité de rome
notre appartenance à l'union européenne
à l'euro et à l'otan d'une part le
verrouille entièrement tous les choix
politiques c'est à dire que les
élections sont désormais vidé de
substance
en fait on a un plan de vol comme pour
un avion qui s'applique quel que soit le
commandant de bord qu'ils soient de
droite ou de gauche et les français le
voient et d'ailleurs on commence à le
comprendre
ils votent à droite évoque aujourd'hui
un problème politique cette politique
qui nous oblige qui oblige maquereau a
supprimé les sf qui l'obligent à démolir
des services publics les privatiser on
est en train de privatiser
f sncf qui s'attaquent ou un autre au
droit du travail
aujourd'hui crédité de moins de 1% des
intentions de vote le 26 mai lui p r
dénonce l'attitude des médias nationaux
qui refuserait de lui donnait la parole
alors qu'il compterait 34 mille
adhérents et des adhésions en hausse
quotidiennement reste qu'il faudra aussi
convaincre les électeurs moins d'un sur
deux pourrait se déplacer aux urnes
avant de pouvoir monter à la tribune du
parlement pour faire passer ses idées
que je serai au parlement européen et je
prendrai la parole à chaque fois pour
dénoncer les actes anti démocratiques de
la commission européenne pour dénoncer
cette machinerie bureaucratiques qui
coûtent des sommes tout à fait
considérable et pour montrer aux
français que la seule possibilité c'est
de sortir de l'union européenne une
centaine de personnes étaient présentes
à rambouillet pour ce meeting de
françois asselineau le scrutin est prévu
le 26 mai il reste encore une semaine de
vacances pour la zone c'est l'occasion
de partir à la découverte des monuments
égyptiens à l'univers de star wars lego
permettent de reconstruire toutes les
histoires
l'association de passionnés de ces
petites briques de construction breezy
expose ses collections à l'espace
philippe noiret aux clayes-sous-bois
jusqu'à dimanche visite au sens de l'art
de la brique avec marylène iapichino
visiter les plus grands monuments du
monde n'a géré entre les poissons de cet
aquarium tout en couleurs l'exposition
légaux fait voyager d'univers en univers
c'est un travail qu'elle dure un peu
plus d'un an que le temps d'organiser de
visiter la salle de prévoir comment
organiser
l'exposition trouver des oeuvres et
pourra les amener toutes ses
installations proviennent des
collections personnelles de sept membres
de l'association yvelinoise brésil des
passionnés de la brique en plastique
parmi eux maxime est fier d'exposer pour
la première fois ses lego star wars
un jour j'ai fait une expo est prise
depuis j'attendais plus longtemps enfin
on prend du temps
allez construire
faux et on prend du plaisir à les
contrer si les différends durent à ma
fenêtre une poussée de créativité
l'association a prévu un espace de
construction où l'imagination et les
talents d'architecte déco s'exprime plus
fait d'abord des escaliers puis je fais
le tour la barre après je commence à
faire avant de retrouver le monde réel
on n'oublie pas de chercher les
personnages incongrus glisser dans ce
monument égyptiens nous ne révélerons
pas notre secret mais nous en avons déjà
trouvé quelques uns porter les vêtements
de ses parents pour faire comme les
grands on l'a tous déjà fait une fois de
se souvenir d'enfance julien caidos on a
fait une exposition
les clichés ont été réalisés au coeur
des écoles du lion courtoise
l'exposition est à découvrir à l'hôtel
de ville après les mots le cliché julien
caïd ans a fait poser des centaines
d'enfants
ce photographe professionnelle leur a
demandé de s'habiller avec un vêtement
d'adultes d'un de leurs parents c'était
une façon de parler du vêtement à
travers le prisme
de l'enfance est un prisme de
spontanéité de
on va dire quelque chose depuis naturel
dehors de mon travail artistique je suis
je suis photographe professionnel donc
je travaille autour du portrait d' pour
les indices tendent et des institutions
je fais de la photographie de mode aussi
j'ai déjà fait des photographies
d'enfants pour des magazines et pour des
catalogues de vêtements donc c'est vrai
que c était un peu l'élément déclencheur
de cette idée julien caloz veux parler
de leurs projections dans l'âge adulte
la construction de leur identité 150
clichés d'enfants guyancourt toit de 6 à
10 ans réalisée dans des écoles de la
ville les enfants ils ont voilà c'est
spontanéité la dent en tout cas quand il
pose devant un objectif qui est quand
même quelque chose de plus facile à
capter que qu'un adulte je voulais pas
non plus quelque chose de trop figée
donc c'est vrai que nous passons à notre
rubrique ça s'est passé comme chaque
vendredi retour sur l'actualité à
travers nos archives et alors que la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lance un appel
à projets jusqu'au 4 mars pour
l'aménagement de la colline d'elancourt
dans le cadre des jo de 2024 retour en
1997 et vous allez voir que depuis plus
de 20 ans et les idées ne manquent pas
[Musique]
imaginez un instant vous êtes en été
1998 et là des exploits des footballeurs
qui dispute la coupe du monde vous
chaussez vos skis et vous vous élancez
duo de la toute nouvelle piste de ski
aménagé sur la colline de la revanche à
elancourt avant d'aller manger au
restaurant d'altitude ce rêve n'en est
peut-être pas un si l'on en croit david
chevallier ce dernier réussit un bel
effet d'annoncé en présentant son projet
de parc consacré à la glisse et au ski
en vie nouvelle lors de l'émission du 19
janvier de capital sur m6 animer la
colline de la revanche sommet de l'île
de france a toujours été envisagée entre
les travaux d'un concours étudiant le
projet d'une église ou d'un restaurant
cette nouvelle idée fruit de la
réflexion de huit associés se veut
particulièrement ambitieuse david
chevalier nous ont fait nous avons voulu
et ça fait partie du cahier des charges
ils ont voulu développer le concept de
la montagne en ville c'est à dire qu'on
a lorsqu'on arrivera sur ce site on aura
l'impression
et bien d'être à la montagne d'abord et
principalement un espace de glisse
artificiel ici en blanc avec une
remontée mécanique
une piste
le rouge grand public ici un espace
snowboard sur la partie droite sur un
autre versant de la colline et je vais
incliné la la maquette on voit une autre
remontée mécanique qui va desservir
d'autres types de pistes d'abord des
pistes de vtt
alors on les voit serpenter un petit peu
partout sont les petits tracé marron
vous voyez là je peux aussi tourner
encore sont les voir encore sur le sur
le versant reste que le montage
financier n'est pas encore fait et que
200 millions cent à trouver novice en la
matière les associés de rock convaincre
de la validité du projet une garantie
qui attendra le pea propriétaire du
terrain au même titre que le san ou la
mairie d'elancourt avant de s'engager
plus en avant même si l'idée paraît
séduisante
[Musique]
et dimanche c'est la fête des
grands-mères l'occasion de partager un
moment chaleureux et pourquoi pas
d'aller au cinéma voici une proposition
retrouvez cette semaine au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa une programmation jeune
public qui s'inscrit dans un festival
dont on est partenaire cette année
encore qui est télérama enfants nous
organisons deux événements ce week end
samedi 2 et dimanche 3 mars
nous commencerons par une journée
japonisation à 14 heures marie est la
fleur de la sorcière suivi à 16 heures
du dernier mamoru hosoda mirail ma
petite soeur et enfin pour la première
fois sur les écrans en france l'un des
premiers films de jeux de hayao miyazaki
le château de cagliostro ensuite
dimanche 3 mars nous vous proposerons
une avant-première à 16h30 d'un très
très joli film d'animation qui s'appelle
tito et les oiseaux réalisé par gustavo
steinberg
c'est un film d'animation brésilien
alors qui reprend une partie de la crise
politique que vit le résident
actuellement
alors ce n'est pas du tout un film à la
remise ou larmoyant mais il est quand
même question pour un groupe d'enfants
intrépides de sauver le monde et de
vaincre la peur qui finalement
en gangrène le brésil et le monde
je suis immunisé contre la peur car ce
jour là j'ai décidé que plus jamais je
n'aurais peur et que je prouverai que
mon père avait raison pour les oiseaux
l'actualité dans le reste de l'île de
france avec nos confrères via grand
paris chaîne disponible sur la tnt
[Musique]
en transport la ligne a est très
empruntée mais restent difficiles
d'accès pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite de ce constat la ratp poursuit
ses aménagements sur le réseau reportage
améliorer l'accès des transports aux
personnes en situation de handicap
la ratp poursuit ses d'aménagement sur
le réseau après la ligne e une c'est la
ligne a du rer qui est récompensé la
gare de châtelet les halles a reçu le
label cap'handéo nouveauté elle peut
désormais mieux accueillir les personnes
en situation de handicap moteur pour les
associations et pour les personnes qui
souffrent d'un handicap c'est aussi un
message pour eux pour leur dire la ratp
aujourd'hui très présents sur ce sujet
est très engagé
on n'a pas des remèdes à tous et à
miracle à tous mais on a on peut faire
beaucoup de choses et on est en train de
les faire et c'est pour ça qu'on veut
généraliser cette démarche à l'ensemble
à l'ensemble de notre réseau
cette sonnette d'alarmé par exemple
permet d'avertir instantanément un agent
de la ratp
les personnes à mobilité réduite peuvent
aussi les prévenir en scannant ce qrcode
grâce à leur smartphone ce meilleur
accueil pas surtout par la formation de
950 agents de la ratp
les personnes en fauteuil roulant
peuvent nous contacter par interfax
elles peuvent se présenter dans
n'importe quel point de vente delà de la
gare et ensuite elles peuvent elles se
rendent en tête de quais où sont situés
les passerelles pour accéder au train
donc ensuite nous dépêcher un agent sur
place on positionne la personne en
fauteuil derrière le conducteur et
ensuite elle sera réceptionné à sa gare
d'arrivée en 2021
toutes les stations rer des lignes a et
b seront accessibles aux personnes en
situation de handicap
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'information lundi dans le 7-8
journal dès 18 heures et d'ici là
n'oubliez pas dimanche c'est la fête des
grands mères
bonne fête à toutes les mamies passer un
excellent week end
[Musique]